we've got something really great because
it starts with David beg now it's a
story about unconditional love and
support and how it lifted a family
through a time of grief so think of this
earlier this year three young children
in Missouri lost their father and their
mother just four months apart their
Community rallied around them and
relatives gave them a new home then the
family faced a new set of health
challenges wow our lead National
correspondent this is a good part David
Bagnell went to Saint to a St Louis
suburb to meet this amazing and amazing
as a word blended family
three six
days
as much as Gregory Hobb tried
he was unable to outsmart time
[Music]
his song 369 loves of mine was a tribute
to his three children
It Was Written after he was diagnosed
with colon cancer and told had just
months
[Music]
tell me about that song I listened to it
and I love it so 369 is the ages of the
his kids so Jane Max and Henry Henry
being the oldest and he just goes
through and describes
um
Heather
sorry they're each each a love of his
and why he loves him
just a little about them
[Music]
what Greg didn't know when he wrote that
song was that he and his wife Megan were
both running out of time
Chris the Lieber is Megan's twin sister
what happened I
she just died suddenly she was sitting
on the couch with her brother-in-law and
all the kids were playing upstairs
and she just took her last breath and
died four months after Greg died from
cancer Megan died due to Cardiac Arrest
she was just 40 years old
she had an undiagnosed heart condition
Krista was tasked with telling her twin
sister's children how did they react
Henry had tears right away
I just told him you know we're just
going to be a bigger family now and
we're going to be here for you and I
want you to know you're never going to
be alone
ever you're going to be taken care of
seemingly overnight 40 year old Krista
and her 37 year old husband Dave went
from three children to six one dog to
two and they did it all without even
hesitating can I have those they're just
one big gang you know the cousin crew
everything in this house comes in pairs
now the dogs
the boys
for Henry who is now 11. the memory of
his mom and dad is ever strong I used to
have like long talks with like Daddy
Emma we'd like walk everywhere we just
talk about the future like what what
will happen like
he's nice and calm am I miss most about
mommy just watching chills with her
talking to her like mostly just talking
like little things I miss that
dressing it's been about four months
since Megan died
and Henry and his siblings are now
easily settling into a life with their
aunt uncle and cousins and that's in
part because of the community that
swarmed in when their world came
crashing down after Greg died and then
after Megan died there was this Village
of people some strangers right who came
together and said what to you how can we
help what can we do some people would do
something as small as help with a cat
other people donated lots of money there
was nothing too small and nothing too
big and I it all added together to like
be this kind of unified front of
stability for the kids and because of
that support in the midst of
insurmountable grief there has been Joy
the laughter the children just being
kids extended family all huddled
together around the Thanksgiving table
decorating the Christmas tree
taking the new family Christmas photo
[Music]
there have been lessons too for everyone
like making your health a priority
you see shortly after Greg died Dave was
diagnosed with an autoimmune disease and
you've been putting off how you were
feeling for a while yeah I was feeling
things and things were happening and I
just chalked it up too
stress then came Krista's Health shock
that she thought was stress you started
feeling something funny I had been
feeling
palpitations and shortness of breath
since
either the pandemic or Greg's cancer
diagnosis both the same time but that's
around when I started feeling it
and I thought like my sisters is just
anxiety but after her twin sister died
Krista decided to get her heart checked
just in case and what did they tell you
I have a Long QT syndrome
which is
your heart
has an electrical conductivity issue it
can cause sudden death fainting seizures
I told Dave I
my sister saved my life you know her I
say her death was not in vain
there's a bigger picture here
and how old are the twins
one everything that this family has been
going through reminds them that life is
fragile
but with the help of a village and with
unwavering love
life marches on because it has to
because the alarm clock still goes off
in the morning the school bell still
rings
beyond the grief the hop kids have found
happiness in this home how would you
describe the kids now
I love them I love them so much
um
they are really resilient they're okay
they truly are they're okay and no we
may not be able to outsmart time
[Music]
but maybe it's not about that anyway
who's that me
looks like me yeah what is the takeaway
don't wait for tomorrow to come
be here in this moment rely on the
kindness of strangers when it comes
thank goodness for counseling and the
schools involvement and the kinds of
these strangers
and all the friends and family that have
surrounded us and made us feel love
because these kids feel it too
we all do
[Music]
how much David can that family take the
dad died of colon cancer at 37 37 and
then the mom dies of a heart and then
the aunt and uncle discover oh so
they're they're ill right I want you to
know that this family is okay that's the
point of the story they are in a good
place they are in a hopeful place and
they are surrounded by a community of
strangers and well-known folks who have
embraced them yeah I like what she said
don't it's okay the kindness of
strangers rely on that and I like what
he said don't wait for tomorrow yeah I I
always struggle with these kind of
stories because I always think if you do
the right thing you're kind to people do
treat others as you want to be treated
but bad stuff still happens to really
good people and we can't explain it it's
just how it is oh my Angelo used to
always be so obsessed after every storm
cloud there's a rainbow yeah yeah and
that's what this family has learned and
I hope that a takeaway for everyone here
and everybody watching is that listen to
your body when something seems a little
yes make an appointment yeah yeah go get
it checked yeah that's the takeaway
that's the Public Service of this family
opening up their heart yeah and their
tears for all of us and if you see
someone that needs help and you can
offer help
just give a little do it man because it
feels good to do it yeah like the people
of the St Louis area there yeah David
Beckner thank you very much